This video is brought to you by surf shark. VPN.
Yeah.
Hey wise, crack Greg here today.
We're going to talk about why you don't really need to be afraid of some AI
fueled robot with AKA's farms coming to snuff you out.
Now really talk about the Terminator series tends to center around fears of the
calming robo apocalypse. You know, the day when a bunch of roided up,
our D finally come for us.
Absolutely will not stop ever until you are
dead.
But what if the Terminator is really wanting us not about some far fetched
apocalypse, but a more subtle danger that's already here.
We'll explain in this wisecrack condition on the Terminator series.
And of course, spoilers ahead. But before we get into it,
I want to give a shout out to this week's sponsor surf shark VPN.
It's no secret that you don't have much privacy on the internet these days.
However, there is a way that you can protect yourself online,
and that is by using a VPN,
a VPN sends your information through an encrypted tunnel.
So you can safely use your passwords without the fear of hackers,
stealing your information.
A VPN can also protect you from targeted ads and other pesky data trackers.
When you use surf shark VPN, you can use your account on any of your devices.
So, you know, you're always protected surf shark. Isn't just a VPN.
It also offers additional features like clean web,
which blocks ads and now where they may pop up while browsing.
There are other feature blind search protects your browse from serving you
targeted ads or sponsored sites. If you use the link in the description,
they use the promo code wise crack.
You can get served shark VPN for 83% off that normal annual price.
Plus three extra months for free go to surf shark.deal/wisecrack.
I hit the link in the description,
protect yourself online and download surf shark VPN today.
And now a quick recap,
when an AI system designed to run America's defense network becomes self-aware.
It decides the safest course of action is to nuke the hell out of humanity.
And honestly, I get it anyway.
After the mushroom clouds disperse a war rages on between man and machine until
the robot army decides to send a Terminator back in town with one mission,
kill this perfectly nice lady, Sarah Connor,
before she gives birth to the future leader of the human resistance,
but humans from the future send back their own soldier to protect her and the
races on who will get the Sarah Connor first and change the course of history.
Come with me.
If you want to live subsequent films in the series have given us good Arnold,
bad on all and stay at home. Dad on him.
His name is Mateo.
I met his mother Alicia a few months after they killed John.
But each new installment revolves around the same basic premise and evil AI
tries to kill us all.
And a robo soldier goes back in time to try and save us all.
Even people drink hot coffee through straws.
While the seagulls are really leaned into the Saifai action thing.
The original is essentially a horror film, like many classics classes.
It sees a cold-hearted human, but not human entity stalking relentlessly.
After what film scholars call a final girl,
AKA the female character faded this vibe, all the villains books.
I'm like other horror antagonists, but exactly like Mark Zuckerberg,
the Terminator puts the cold ruthless precision of a computer into a human
body. It's creepy as hell.
This basic juxtaposition between humanity and dead eyed machine like logic is
what makes the movie so scary.
It also makes you wonder what Siri's really capable of.
I could kill you and they'd never find the body.
Personally that's way scarier to me than global nuclear war,
but let's put killer robots aside because the real strip of the series
commentary is the way it highlights the subtle,
dangerous already posed by existing technology.
The original movie was set and released in 1984,
at which point our daily lives have become increasingly automated and
increasingly relying on machines and it's is dependence on technology that
primes many of the Terminator's victims for the kill take Sarah's roommate,
ginger. While her boyfriend is being attacked by our Burley, Android, and dater,
she remains blissfully unaware. Thanks to the headphones,
blaring those irresistible eighties tunes
Cut the 2020.
And we're so dependent on technology that I for one have basically high glued my
AirPods and some of my heroes and not to sound like a bloomer,
but I'd say that spending most of our lives on screens often cuts us off from
the outside world.
And it's not just about how you almost got hit by a car cause you were sexting
either. It's also,
our technology stops working for us throughout the first movie.
The communication technology that the characters rely on constantly fails. Them.
Phone calls are missed voicemails, go unchecked.
And Ginger's boyfriend embarrassed himself by launching into a steamy monologue
to his girlfriend's roommate.
Off of my team, who is, this.
Happens to the best of us. I've been there in matters. Believe me.
And even after the police know that Sarah is in trouble,
they still can't get off.
Call her. I just called call.
Her again. And when she tries to call them.
Please keep transferring me around. I'm going to give him another try.
Yeah.
The web of connections that is our safety net comes unraveled in a time of real
crisis. And that was just the 1984. These days.
If the internet went out, the world would probably collapse in the chaos.
Basically when so much of our communication takes place from a distance and as
mediated by technology, we're left vulnerable in more ways than one.
The scene that was has sex with her boyfriend without removing her headphones
can even be read as a comic indication of how technology has come to interrupt.
Even our most intimate forms of contact.
A study from last year found that 20% of air pot users have enjoyed a
similar experience hopefully while listening to this American life. However,
the recording that plays out in response to the polices on answered calls
indicates an even deeper problem.
Hi there, you're talking to a machine.
The T 800 tracks Sarah down by impersonating her mother on the phone showing how
easily good technology can trick us today.
Twitter bots and chatbots are like, uh,
both effective because they give us the sensation of speaking to a real human
being. Of course, whether they're being used around us up or calm us down,
they elicit an emotional response and that response can be exploited.
And this is a fear that becomes more potent every year.
The TA hundreds vocal mimicry, might've been by back in 1984,
but it's eerily real. And the age of deep fakes.
I don't want to have to say because who knows when you're going to run into
these people.
Just last year and the AI was able to impersonate Joe Rogan's voice well enough
to convince listeners.
They were speaking with the podcast to himself at the same time,
visual deep fakes are becoming an easy way to spread very convincing
misinformation.
President Trump is a total and complete.
Now you see, I would never say these things,
at least not in a public address,
but someone else would someone like
Jordan.
Okay, cool. These days,
fears of being walled into a false sense of security by computer tricks is
very, very real. And Samantha,
I don't care if you're actually a 71 year old inmate named rod. Well,
we have with special girl and I'll never regret it. And of course,
unlike in 1984,
computers are now integral to the fabric of our daily lives.
This reality was explored in a fun,
if not completely successful sequel from last year, Terminator,
dark fate. Once again,
the series tries to warn us about the very real technological threats we face
today. Threats,
McKinsey Davis's robot arm can possibly protect us from dark fate puts its
hero, Danny in much the same position as Sarah and John Connor before her
aware that a single minded killing machine is on Hertz rail and desperate to
disappear. Of course,
it's basically impossible to get off the grid when the grid is.
Now, anyone with a phone is a walking sensor platform. However,
intersection every gas station in seven 11 has cameras.
Nobody walks through this world without leaving a digital trail, a mile wide.
Throughout the movie.
The red nine is able to track its prey by tapping the huge web internet
connected devices that now span the globe and the original film.
The T 800 happens to be in Sarah's apartment. When she leaves a voicemail,
revealing her location.
Pick up if you're there, I'm at this place.
Nine doesn't have to rely on such old tricks.
Thanks to our smartphones and other devices.
We all leave a Godzilla sized digital footprint everywhere we go,
while it may save us from getting stranded like this,
it also makes it impossible to hide.
Why them from facial recognition technology or from Facebook harvesting are very
personal data and short on water, which computers track our every move.
Isn't the stuff, a futuristic Sapphire.
It's a world we and Danny already living in.
Hey, might as well be wearing a tracking bracelet.
But it's not all stolen personal data and targeted Facebook ads.
The Terminator films have always centered around the most terrifying
technological risk of all.
What happens when computers are the ones with the guns.
And before you laugh at the thought of your room,
but pulling a gun or you consider this,
the Korean border is being patrolled by robotics, centuries,
equipped with actual machine guns, that'll be cleared.
The manufacturers maintained that the bot still requires human authorization to
fire. So we are yet in a world with fully automated death machines.
The thing she was seen headed that way as in dark fate,
we witnessed an increase in use of lethal drones,
particularly by the United States,
which moves us further towards a more mechanized vision of warfare.
Recently,
the U S agency that researches and develops emerging warfare technology
announced that it has successfully tested and autonomous drone swarm.
It's a Bob killing machine. Oh great.
That's great.
So even if we won't be seeing anything like a T 800 stumping down the street any
day soon,
the military possibilities of our increasingly advanced computers should
certainly give us pause,
which brings us back to the real problem with our continued panic about
interconnected networks of murder and leather clamp kill bots.
Not only does it freak us out,
but it also distracts us from the much more concrete dangers we face today,
the world, the pigging and the Terminator isn't coming any time soon,
but there are plenty of potential. Dystopia is leaking land. And along the way,
if we're not careful from the privacy threat,
you carry around in your pocket to that deep fake of you cheating on your spouse
with their dentists,
the computers we should be wary of already here before all the time is spent
teaching us to be terrified of anything with wires.
The Terminator series always ends on a hopeful note because technological
progress is not preordained.
We get to choose what shaped the world of tomorrow will take.
Especially if you're Elon Musk come, man,
don't be lying at its core.
The Terminator series is about what technology can do to us.
If we're not careful and about questioning the role computers should play in our
lives.
It's great that we can ask Alexa to set a timer for four 20 to take our
vitamins.
It's less great when we were linked with all of our privacy in the process.
So what do you think wise crack, how far is too far when it comes to computers?
So we keep pressing forward and hope things turn out more next generation and
judgment day,
or should we be a little more worried about the rise of the machines?
Let us know in the comments big thanks to our Patriots for your support,
terminate that subscribe button and as always, thanks for watching.
[Inaudible].